Stell dir vor du könntest von jedem Objekt
in deinem Haushalt die Farbe ändern.
Stell dir vor du könntest manipulieren, wie
Licht mit Objekten interagiert.
Klingt wie die Zukunft, oder?
Vor ein paar Wochen war ich in Karlsruhe auf
der CODE_n, einer Messe für Start Up Unternehmen.
Ich habe mich da mit vielen, jungen Unternehmern
unterhalten, die mir alle von ihren Erfindungen
und Ideen für die Zukunft erzählt haben.
Und einer davon hat mich besonders beeindruckt. Peiman Hosseini.
- "I am Peiman Hosseini.
I'm the CTO of Bodle Technologies."
Peiman hat lange an einer Idee gearbeitet,
die so genial ist, dass sie 2014 in der renommierten
Wissenschaftszeitschrift Nature veröffentlicht
wurde.
Eine Technologie mit der man Licht beeinflussen
kann.
Wenn Licht auf ein Objekt trifft, dann wird
es immer zu einem Teil absorbiert und zu einem
anderen Teil reflektiert.
Ein Objekt wie ein Spiegel reflektiert das
meiste Licht,
deswegen kann man auf der Spiegeloberfläche
andere Objekte sehen.
Ein bunter Gegenstand wie zum Beispiel ein roter Schal
absorbiert hingegen das meiste Licht und reflektiert
nur die roten Wellenlängen zurück.
Peimans Technologie macht sich jetzt das Phänomen
der Interferenz zunutze.
Interferenz bedeutet, dass sich Wellen gegenseitig
beeinflussen, wenn sie sich überlagern.
Sie können sich gegenseitig verstärken oder
abschwächen.
Und das gilt für Wellen im Wasser, für Schallwellen
und auch für Licht.
Mithilfe mehrerer, sehr dünner Schichten,
die übereinander liegen, kann Peiman beeinflussen
wie verschiedene Wellenlängen des Lichts
mit der Oberfläche interagieren.
Der Trick ist, dass die einzelnen Schichten
genau so dünn sind, dass das reflektierte
Licht einer Schicht mit dem reflektierten
Licht einer anderen Schicht interferriert
- "But if you put them in a certain way light will
interfere within the structure a little bit
like the butterfly wings, that have this very very nice, extremly saturated color.
But they don't have that color, it's just
that the structure is giving that color."
Im Gegensatz zum roten Schal hat das Material
selber hier gar nicht die Farbe, die es zurück reflektiert.
Allein durch die Struktur des Materials wird
eine bestimmte Wellenlänge des Lichts zurückgeworfen.
Das ist an und für sich noch nichts besonderes.
Das Phänomen nennt sich optische
Interferenz und man findet es sogar in der Natur
zum Beispiel in Schmetterlingsflügeln oder in Öl-Filmen
auf Wasser.
Das wirklich geniale kommt jetzt: Mithilfe
eines Stromimpulses kann man die Struktur
von einer der Schichten verändern, sodass
die Interferenz einen ganz anderen,
vorher festgelegten, Effekt hat.
Das funktioniert mit Phasenwechselmaterial,
einem Stoff, der zum Beispiel auch bei wiederbeschreibbaren
DvDs verwendet wird.
Durch einen einfachen Strom-Impuls kann man
den amorphen Stoff kristallin werden lassen.
Das verändert den Brechungsindex und damit
die Geschwindigkeit des Lichts im Material.
Plötzlich interferrieren die Lichtwellen
nach der Reflektion anders als vorher.
Und von außen betrachtet kann dadurch das
Material, das vorher rot aussah zum Beispiel
grün erscheinen.
Und das funktioniert mit jeder Wellenlänge
oder Farbe, die man vorher festgelegt hat.
Sowohl vor, als auch nach der Veränderung
befindet sich das Material in einem sogenannten
Solid State, einem Festkörperzustand.
Das heißt es kostet nur Energie, von einem
in den anderen Zustand zu wechseln.
Danach bleibt das Material so lange in einem
Zustand und somit in einer Farbe, bis wieder
ein Impuls gegeben wird.
Allein für diese Technologie fallen mir schon
Tausende genialer Anwendungsbeispiele ein.
Vielleicht Tapeten, die auf Knopfdruck ihre
Farbe ändern können?
Heute blau, morgen weiß...
...und zur Halloween-Party blutrot.
Das ganze würde sogar als Autolack funktionieren,
weil die Schichten nur wenige Nanometer dick
sind; sie sind flexibel.
Aber die Technologie kann noch mehr.
Denn sie funktioniert auch außerhalb des
sichtbaren Lichtspektrums.
Man kann die Schichten zum Beispiel auch durchsichtig
erscheinen lassen und mit ihnen nur Infrarotlicht
beeinflussen.
Ein Fenster, das im Sommer die Wärme des
Sonnenlichts draußen hält, aber im Winter
reinläßt kann Unmengen an Heizenergie sparen.
Ein kleiner Strom-Impuls genügt, um indirekt die Temperatur im ganzen Raum zu kontrollieren.
Peiman hat mir außerdem erzählt, dass man
auch alle Farben des Lichts gleichzeitig kontrollieren
und somit die Lichtdurchlässigkeit von Glas
steuern kann.
Man könnte also Brillen herstellen, die mit
einem schnellen Tap auf dem Smartphone zu
Sonnenbrillen werden.
Oder Windschutzscheiben im Auto, die automatisch
abdunkeln, wenn man geblendet wird.
- "So there are all sorts of applications that
one can think of.
That is actually one of our problems.
We have to focus something down, what we want
to do.
And that's what we're doing at the moment."
Aber das ist alles nichts gegen die meiner
Meinung nach wichtigste und weitreichendste
Einsatzmöglichkeit für diese Technologie:
als Bildschirm.
Laut Peiman kann man seine Technologie in
Pixel-Form verbauen und hat dann einen Bildschirm,
den man wie jeden LCD oder OLED Bildschirm
mit einem Computer ansprechen kann.
Nur mit einem riesigen Unterschied: Der Bildschirm
benötigt keine Hintergrundbeleuchtung.
Weil die Technologie mit Licht funktioniert,
das auf die Oberfläche fällt und reflektiert wird,
könnte man auf sein Handy gucken, wie
auf eine Zeitschrift:
Mit ganz natürlichem Licht aus dem Raum.
Das hat einige große Vorteile, der offensichtlichste:
Man spart Akku, denn das Beleuchten unserer
großen Smartphonebildschirme verbraucht mit
Abstand am meisten davon.
Aussehen würde das dann, wie das Display
eines Kindles, nur mit Farbe.
Oder wie eine ganz normale Zeitung, nur eben
dass sich der Inhalt bewegen kann.
So ein reflektives Display ist angenehmer
für die Augen und, das ist besonders für Gamer
interessant, kann innerhalb einer Mikrosekunde
seinen Zustand ändern und somit problemlos
mehrere Hundert Bilder pro Sekunde darstellen.
Falls diese Screen-Technologie soweit entwickelt
wird, dass sie in Reihe produziert werden
kann, könnte das eine wahre Revolution für
Bildschirme bedeuten.
Screens in Fenstern und Spiegeln, die jederzeit
durchsichtig werden können, die Motorhaube
als Kommunikationsplattform und Kontaktlinsen-Displays.
Jede Fläche im Alltag könnte ein Computerbildschirm
sein und würde keinen Strom verbrauchen,
solange sich die der Inhalt des Bildes nicht
verändern soll.
Das klingt nach einem Science-Fiction-Film,
aber die Technologie dazu ist heute schon da.
Jetzt ist es an Peiman und seinem Start-Up
weiter zu forschen und zu testen, Fehler auszubügeln
und die Technologie soweit zu perfektionieren,
dass die vielen Anwendungsbeispiele realisiert
werden können.
Ich bin mega gespannt, wann und wie wir wieder
von ihm hören werden.
Zur CODE_n gebracht hat mich übrigens der
Photonik Campus, für den ich über den
Strategieprozess Photonik berichtet habe.
Hier hat sich die Branche der Photonik, der
Wissenschaft rund ums Licht, getroffen um
über die wichtigsten Technologien der nächsten
5 Jahre zu sprechen.
Immer wichtiger werden zum Beispiel die Photonik
im Auto und die Beleuchtung in der Smart City.
Wenn ihr mehr darüber erfahren wollt, dann
schaut euch doch meinen Bericht zur CODE_n an,
den ich hier gemacht habe.
Und wenn ihr ein naturwissenschaftliches Fach
Studiert, dann könnte die Photonik Akademie
für euch interessant sein. Dazu hab ich hier ein Video gemacht.
Ansonsten vielen Dank für's Zuschauen bis zum nächsten Mal.
Euer Cedric.